- [Announcer] This Great
Big Story was made possible
by Shell. Make the future.
- [Narrator] One man was so inspired
by the science fiction
he consumed as a kid.
- I am a machine!
- [Narrator] He dedicated
his life to building robots
that help mankind.
(futuristic music)
Yoshiyuki Sankai is the CEO
of the billion dollar company Cyberdyne,
which happens to be the same name
as the manufacturer of
cyborgs from "The Terminator."
It took Sankai over two decades
to build an exoskeleton that
uses brain waves to move.
He named the final product HAL,
a name was made famous by the
AI in "2001: A Space Odyssey."
- Well, that's far safer than allowing HAL
to continue running things.
- One, two, three.
- [Narrator] This technology helps people
who need it the most,
people like Masami Kawasaki.
(bright, driving music)